Joe Biden was one of the first world
leaders to visit Israel after October
the 7th the two leaders have spoken
often since and now even after Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu again
publicly rejected the US policy of an
independent Palestine Biden is reluctant
to abandon him asked at the White House
if a two-state solution was impossible
with Netanyahu in power he replied
sharply no and rejected the idea of
cutting Aid in respon to such a public
disagreement on Israel a given what said
about one St I think we'll be able to
something what is
that there are a number of types of
two-state solutions there's a number of
countries that are members of the UN
that are still don't have their own
military a number of states that have
limitation and so I think there's ways
in which this could work the two leaders
spoke on Friday the first call in 26
days a sign many observers believe of
growing frustration in Washington that
Israel continues to undermine the
president on scaling back the war on
avoiding civilian casualties on the
future but the White House says the call
had been in the works for a while and
there was no split between the two
governments this isn't about you know
trying to twist uh twist somebody's arm
or um or or or force a change in their
thinking president uh uh sorry prime
minister Netanyahu has has made clear
his concerns about that President Biden
has made clear his uh strong conviction
that a two-state solution is still the
right path ahead one analyst says in an
election year Biden is making a huge
miscalculation by not publicly
criticizing Netanyahu politically this
is a disaster for for Biden I think he
frankly is just an ideologue who really
really believes in the Israeli project
and is wetted to this naive assumption
that by being nice to Netanyahu he might
be able to get the Israelis to
compromise even though that has been
shown over and over again that that
simply does not work us lawmakers who've
been largely supportive of Israel are
said to be growing frustrated with
Netanyahu and insist by ruling out a
two-state solution he's also ruling out
a long-term peace settlement and that's
why Biden is talking about Aid because
some are considering changing the
conditions for America's multi-million
dollar support for Israel Alan Fischer
Al jazer
Washington make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer